avec nous ce soir alexandre boulerice
candidat dans rosemont la petite patrie
pour le npd bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion 214 milliards de dollars en cinq
ans de nouvelles dépenses 166 milliards
de nouveaux revenus et pas de retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire non plus c'est
pas dans les coeurs carton est ce que
l'équilibré budgétaire pour le npd
quelque chose qui n'est pas important
parce qu'on a présenté puis qu'on offre
aux électeurs aux citoyens et aux
citoyennes c'est vraiment une
proposition très progressiste de
réinvestir ce une stratégie pour
investir dans les gens pour investir
dans les secteurs qui en ont besoin
notamment la santé puis et et le
logement alors je pense que l'important
puis vous regardez notre cadre financier
on maitien race un ratio dette pib qui
est stable hitman qui diminue souvent la
cinquième année pour voir à peu près 46
pour ça ils nous on pense que c'est
responsable c'est la bonne chose à faire
pour les gens pour les travailleurs et
travailleuses pour les entreprises pour
la relance économique et faire des plats
de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire une
période de 10 ans il ya tellement
d'incertitudes lada que c'est pas
réaliste c'est un peu rêver en couleurs
mais 214 milliards c'est trois fois les
nouveaux investissements prévus par le
parti libéral du canada il ya quand même
une capacité à contrôler les dépenses
pour être capable de soin de revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire ou viser quelque
chose en cinq sept ou dix ans est-ce que
ça pour le npd je repose ma question ce
n'est pas important
je pense qu'il est important c'est de
prendre soin des gens de notre société
d'avoir une société société plus
égalitaire plus juste également faire
face à la crise climatique et pour ça il
faut prendre les moyens alors évidemment
un plan qui est très ambitieux il ya les
investissements mais il ya également les
revenus ont fait quelque chose que les
autres partis font pas on va aller
chercher l'argent là où il est par
exemple l'impôt sur la fortune des gens
qui auront des actes d avoir de plus de
10 millions de dollars c'est quand même
11 à 12 milliards de revenus plus par
annick un gouvernement npd irait
chercher également aussi les gains en
capitaux jusqu'à 75 % des recettes ça
aussi c'est à peu près 10 milliards de
plus qu'on va chercher dans les coffres
de l'état alors oui on n'investit plus
dans logement dans les gens dans la
santé mais on va chercher l'argent là où
il est les ultra riches et les grandes
compagnies je regardais justement dans
votre cadre financier je calculais
toutes les hausses de taxes les hausses
d'impôts que vous proposez pour les
entreprises pour les plus riches sur
cinq ans ça fait à peu près 150 160
milliards de dollars sur cinq ans
certains économistes qui vous dirait que
de trop taxés pourrait faire fuir les
investissements faire fuir des
entreprises est ce que vous êtes
convaincu d'aller chercher ces sommes-là
qui répond à un effet néfaste en
guillemets sur l'économie non on est
confiant parce que on voit aussi avec un
plus grand compétiteur avec les états
unis qui sont aussi dans une une
orientation une direction d'augmenter
les impôts des grandes compagnies et des
multimillionnaires des milliardaires
alors évidemment faut que les gens
sachent que si vous faites moins de 210
1000 $ par année où vous serez pas
toucher si vous êtes une pme vous serez
pas touché non plus au contraire il ya
des mesures qui vont aider nos petites
et moyennes entreprises et puis on va
miser sur des investissements dans les
énergies renouvelables pour être capable
de créer des emplois pour être capable
de faire le virage vers une société à
carbo neutre qui est tellement
nécessaire ouais mais les ultra riches
les plus riches de la société
vont toujours trouver des nouvelles
façons d'échapper aux règles si vous en
mettez trop vous craignez pas d'avoir un
effet inverse de ce que vous recherchez
mais je pense qu'il faut avoir le
courage politique de faire des choix et
pendant des années les gouvernements
conservateurs et libéraux sont traîné
les pieds notamment avec les paradis
fiscaux je rappelle le livre d'alain
deneault une escroquerie légaliser c'est
à dire qu'on peut aller mettre son
argent la barbade aux caïmans et pas
payer d'impôt au québec et au canada
c'est c'est du vol c'est du vol
carrément or on veut éviter ça alors
fort faire des changements
réglementaires et législatifs et c'est
pas vrai qu'on va laisser les plus
riches s'en sortir comme les libéraux de
justin trudeau l'ont fait dans les six
dernières années une chose particulière
dans votre proposition vous avez une
proposition d'impôt sur les profits
excédentaires des grandes entreprises
durant la pandémie donc ça c'est tout à
fait rétroactif là si je mens on part
vous parlez de 14 15 milliards de
dollars en revenus perçus
rétroactivement esthétiquement on peut
faire ça d'aller chercher des impôts
rétroactivement alors qu'ils avaient
d'autres règles à ce moment là je pense
que c'est tout à fait possible pour un
état de faire ce choix là de toute façon
si vous êtes un contribuable vous savez
que revenu canada peut revenir quelques
années en arrière c'est ça existe déjà
donc c'est possible la levée de l'impôt
oui c'est sûr mais je n'ai pas une
hausse d'impôt rétroactive tout à coup
parce que le gouvernement change et puis
voudrait aller chercher l'argent dans le
passé le principe est simple suffit lyon
c'est que il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
énormément souffert pendant la pandémie
à le secteur culturel touristique a
vraiment nos pme en ont arraché mais il
ya aussi des gens qui s'en sont servis
pour s'en mettre plein les poches disons
le carrément les amazones de ce monde
les netflix qui paye même pas d'impôts
vraiment ou au canada après six ans de
règne libéral on peut aller chercher 15
% de plus sur leurs profits si les
compagnies ont peu fait de profits
évidemment on pourra pas le faire alors
on passe de 15 à 30% cette année là pour
la période d'apport démis en 2020 on va
chercher 15 milliards de dollars peu
après sans s'en sert pour construire des
logements très sociaux plai prendre soin
autres membres l'ancien directeur
parlementaire du budget kevin page dit
que vous manquez de transparence
d'explications claires sur la mise en
place de programmes qui viennent toucher
les compétences provinciales qu'on
disait vous avez des choses quand même
très ambitieuses notamment l'assurance
médicaments jusqu'à quel point vous
pouvez réaliser l'ambition de votre
programme alors que par exemple vous ne
vous engagez même pas transférer toutes
les sommes que voudraient les provinces
en matière de santé
dans nos plats on a déjà 68 milliards
sur quatre ans et demi pour la santé
c'est la norme tenais pas les transferts
canadiens en santé un conte veut
augmenter les transferts canadiens en
santé aux provinces on a vu à quel point
c'est absolument essentiel c'est dans
notre plateforme québec également mais
là dessus je veux être que tu réclames
suffit lyon c'est à dire qu' il va
falloir s'asseoir avec les provinces
pour faire une assurance médicaments
public universel comme s'est demandé par
beaucoup de groupes
au québec également même chose pour les
soins dentaires on le sait qu'il va
falloir s'asseoir et les provinces à
l'est d'état ils vont se faire là et
rappelons que la poche asymétrique du
npd va faire en sorte que le québec va
avoir un droit de retrait avec
compensation financière et ça aussi ça
va être une certaine manière de
transférer des sommes au gouvernement du
québec pour le système de santé si veux
pas embarquer d'un nouveau programme ils
vont être compensés ça va augmenter les
revenus monsieur bout le reste vous
serez de notre débat économique qui aura
lieu mardi merci d'y participer merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir faire
plaisir à monsieur fillon revoit pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit